[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
دعوني ابدا معكم واطلب طلب بسيط اطلب من
كل الحاضرين تذكروا معي اول يوم دخلتوا
فيه الى منصات التواصل الاجتماعي اول يوم
سجلتوا فيه في موقع من هذه المواقع كم كان
قبل كم سنه اربع سنين خمس سنين ست عشر
اكيد مده طويله تذكروا معي اول يوم دخلتوا
فيه للصفحه الرئيسيه ماذا وجدتم هل وجدتم
كلما يرضي اهتماماتكم هل وجدتم كلما تحبون
وترغبون في متابعته لا اعتقد كلنا قضينا
وقت نقلب هذه الصفحات ونتابع هذا المحتوى
ونتجنب هذا المحتوى حتى صارت مع الوقت
حساباتنا في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صارت
تفهمنا كلما نفتحها نلقى اهتماماتنا نلقى
ما يجعلنا نجلس ساعات طويله على هذه
المنصات
لكن الاهم السؤال الاهم هو
افكارنا اراءنا نظرتنا للعالم تغيرت بعد
ما دخلنا لهذه المواقع
اعتقد اغلبنا تغير ولو بنسبه بسيطه
نسال هل التغيير كان ايجابي او تغيير سلبي
باعتقادي انا ان التغيير الغالب كانت
تغيير الايجابي لاننا استطعنا ان نرى
العالم بعيون ناس اخرين من كل اقطار
العالم صرنا قادرين على التواصل مع عقول
كبيره مع باحثيا مع الناس لهم تجارب اخرى
لا نستطيع نحن ان نحظى بها
لذلك انا متاكده مئه بالمئه ان مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هي نعمه لا تقدر بثمن
لكني في الفتره الاخيره كنت اقع في مواقف
بالصدفه تكشف لي تغيير كبير في شخصيتي
بطريقه تعامل مع قضايا الحياه هذا التغيير
بالنسبه لي كان غير ايجابي وايضا كان
مرتبط دائما بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
فجعلني افكر
هل يمكن ان يكون لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
او بالاصح بتفاعلي في منصات تواصل اجتماعي
اثر سلبي على طريقه تفكيري وعقليته
ارجو منكم فقط ان تنظروا معي الى محتوى
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي اليس محتوى ضخم
محتوى هائل هل نستطيع تصفحه ولو قضينا طول
العمر نشاهد النصوص والفيديوهات والصور لا
طبعا
محتوى الانترنت محتوى ضخم جدا لذلك جاءت
فكره استخدام فلاتر في هذه المنصات او
بالاخص خوارزميه تقوم بفرز محتوى عند
الانترنت وتعطينا ما نفضله وما نتمنى
مشاهدته
لكنها ايضا لانها مجرد برمجيات لا تعرف
الصح ولا تعرف الخطا قد لا تعطينا المحتوى
الذي نحتاجه اكثر
بالنسبه لي انا اكره اكره جدا السياسه وكل
الاخبار المتعلقه بها وخصوص وخصوصا
الاخبار المحليه لانها طول الفتره هذه
تصيبني بالاحباط ولا احب انني اتابعها
لذلك كنت اتجنب اي فيديو اي صوره اي خبر
فيها بخصوص السياسه
الاحداث التي تحصل في المجتمع لذلك مع
الوقت بدا هذا المحتوى يقل يقل يقل في
صفحه الرئيسيه الى ان اختفى تماما كنت
سعيده بهذا الوضع لكن جاء اليوم الذي ندمت
فيه اشد الندم
اليوم عادي صباح يوم عادي
ذهبت فيه الى الكليه ولكن في طريقي لاحظت
انتشار امني لكن كنت في قلبي هذا الانتشار
الطبيعي في هذا البلاد لكن لما دخلت
الكليه دخلت القاعه عرفت ان الامر ليس
طبيعي ابدا
انصدمت من عدد الطلاب القليل في القاعه
زملائي اين زميلاتي
بالامس كانت اشتباكات كبيره في المنطقه ما
عرفتي الاخبار مليانه مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لكن انا ولا وصلني اي خبر
والنتيجه كانت ان الاشتباكات اشتدت وانا
داخل الكليه
وتعالت اصوات الانفجارات والرصاص وانحبست
انا وزميلاتي القلائل في داخل الكليه حتى
لما انفتحت الطرق هربنا في باص صغير في
الخط البحري مع مدرعات العسكر ومع سيارات
الاسعاف كان الوضع مرعب اخر رعب
عشان كذا روحت البيت وحتى في الموضوع فقدت
انني فعلا انغمست في اهتماماتي التي هي
مهمه بالنسبه لي لكنني ابتعدت عن امور
اخرى ايضا لها اثر في حياتي لذلك قررت
انني يجب ان اضيف على الاقل رشه من كل
موضوع من كل مجال علشان ما يفوتني شيء مهم
في هذا العالم واذا جميعنا اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار ان كل مجال في الحياه له اهميته
لا ضروره نعطيه شويه من مقتنع نتابع بعض
الصفحات اللي ربما ما تكون اهتماماتنا
المركزه لكنها تعطينا معلومات مهمه ومع
بعض نقدر نرفع ثقافه المجتمع اللي نعيش
فيه ونصنع مجتمع مثقف والمجتمع المثقف هو
مجتمع مستقر ومجتمع مزدهر
علشان كده بدات اتابع شويه الاخبار
المحليه
لكني غريب في الموضوع
انا توصلني ما كانت اخبار فقط كانت اخبار
مع اراء وجهات نظر
كل هذه الاراء كل هذا الوجهات النظر كانت
كلها في جانب واحد جانب من يعني جانب اهلي
ابناء منطقتي اصدقائي الذين كنت اتفاعل
معهم بشكل كبير على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي ايضا الصفحات والمجموعات التي
محتواها يناسب تفكيري ويتماشى مع تفضيلات
لكنني معه يعني سعيده في الوضع ما كنت ما
كنت عندي اي مشكله لان الاراء اصلا متعوده
عليها وما عندي فيها مشكله لكن جاء اليوم
اللي انا زعلت فيه من نفسي وحسيت بالحسره
بداخلي كان يوم عادي في الكليه في قاعه
الدرس الذي يبقى تجمع كل الطلاب من كل
المحافظات من كل الخلفيات كانت بجانبي
مجموعه من زملائي وكنا منتظرين الدكتور
زميلتي فتحت موضوع
الاحداث التي حاصله في هذا البلاد بعدين
تكلم بدات تقول ارائها لكن المشكله انه
ارائها كانت مخالفه تماما لارائي تقريبا
تعاكس كل اراءه بذاك الوقت انفجر غضب في
داخلي
وتملكتني العصبيه كنت مستعده في ذاك الوقت
اصيح فوقها كلها كل كلامك غلط
وقف الحوار ولا بيحصل نقاش ولا بيحصل
تفاهم لكني سكت سكت لاني حسيت حسره في
داخلي معقول انا البنت المتعلمه المثقفه
اع
تريني غضب فقط لانه زميلتي لديها راي اخر
معقول متى وصلت الى هذه المرحله
لان هذا الموقف اثر فيه كثير رحت البيت
انطلقت الى منصه تواصل الاجتماعي بحثت في
الموضوع
واللي تبين لي ان الموضوع هذا عباره عن
ظاهره منتشره لدرجه ان المختصين اعطوها
اسماء فبعضهم سماها فقاعه الفلاتر نسبه
الى الفلاتر اللي هي الخوارزميات التي
تفرز محتوى الانترنت
فخلوها وكاننا نحن داخل فقاعه وكل الاراء
التي نحن لا نتماشى معها او ما تعجبنا
معزولين عنها وبعضهم اسناها اسم ثاني
سموها غرفه الصدى غرفه الصداقه يعني ايش
يعني لما تفتح منصه التواصل الاجتماعي او
موقعك على مواصات التواصل الاجتماعي ترى
الاراء التي تدعم وجهه نظرك فقط وكانك
تعطي رايك للناس ورايك هو هو الذي يرجع لك
المشكله من هذه الحادثه انه الاثنين لهم
رايين مختلفين كل واحد فيهم محاط باراء
والناس اللي دعموه في وجهات نظره لما
يلتقوا في الواقع
يحصل نقاش عقيم لا تخرج منه فائده او حلول
والمشكله انه نحن التفاهم
والنقاش هو الذي بخرج اصلا البلاد من
الانشاءات والحروب الى السلام الاستقرار
يجب ان لا تكونوا متعصبين لارانا وكمان
ننسى كيف نتفاعل مع الناس
لذلك بدات انا وعدت نفسي انني كلما يحصل
حاجه في هذه البلاد اروح انا بنفسي ابحث
عن وجهه النظر الاخرى وبس مش كده بس اخذ
النظره الاخرى واقدمها لاسرتي لعائلتي
الناس المحيطين فيه علشان ما ننسى انه نحن
لا نعيش وحدنا على هذه الارض وان الناس
مختلفين خاصه نحن في عدن مكونات مختلفه
اراء مختلفه يجب ان نتعلم ان نستمع الاخر
حتى نصل الى بر السلام مع بعض
اريد ان اتحدث عن قضيه واحده وهي ان
الاراء اصلا كيف كيف نجمع انا كيف نتوصل
الى رايك نتوصل عيار اي معين عن طريق
المؤثرات الخارجيه الاخبار التي تصلنا
المعلومات التي تصنع ونصدقها فاعل معاها
ونطلع على اساسها بوجهه نظر
لكن المشكله ان معظم القصص والاخبار على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي هي غير صحيحه
وهذا اعتماد على دراسه نشرت في 2018 وتقول
بان المعلومه غير الصحيحه تصل بسته اضعاف
سرعه المعلومه الصحيحه
لكن نحن مع الوقت بدانا نطور امكانيات
معينه نفهم انه هذه القصه قد لا تكون
صحيحه خاصه في جيل الشباب الذي بدا يسال
يقول متى حصلت هذه القصه من نشرها متى
نشرت كيف طريقه صياغتها هل ليست الطريقه
احترافيه او هي طريقه جاهله بدانا نفكر
لكن المشكله اننا نجد الجيل الاول الجيل
السابق مازال يتاثر بها بشكل كبير يعني
الخبر او القصه اللي انا
بطرفه عين اعرف انها غير حقيقيه اكيد
هتملا هاتف ابي وامي والمشكله انهم
ينشرونها ايضا تساعدون في نشرها
لماذا هذا الحادثه لماذا وصلوا الى هذا
الوضع
جدا ان الجير السابق متعود على وسائل
الاعلام الرسميه مثل ماذا مثل القنوات
التلفزيونيه مثل الراديو مثل الجرائد هذه
دعم الوسائل الاعلاميه يشرف عليها مخرجون
منتجون صحفيون هي عرضه
للمقاضاءه او للمحاسبه القانونيه وايضا
يمكن للجمهور ان يقرر ان يقاطعها ويتوقف
عن مشاهدتها لكن منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
لا رقيب ولا عتيب تنتشر فيها الاخبار
والمعلومات غير الصحيحه بكميات كبيره لا
نعرف مصدرها ولا نستطيع ايقاف انتشارها
لذلك
مسؤوليه مواجهه انتشار الاخبار الكاذبه
والتوعيه بخطورتها تقع على عاتق الشباب
الجيل الذي تربى مع التكنولوجيا ويعرفها
حق المعرفه هذا الجيل مسؤوليه ايضا مواجهه
اي خطر ينبثق عن منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
واعداد المجتمع لمواجهه مثل هذه الخطوره
حتى ننتقل من مجتمع جاهل غير واعي يسهل
خداعه وقره للنزاعات والحروب الى مجتمع
واعي عاقل يتمسك بالاستقرار والسلام ولا
يفرط فيه ابدا السؤال هو
هل سنستطيع نشر الوعي بين اهلنا والناس
المحيطين بنا هل سنستطيع حمايه مجتمعنا من
التفكك والتنازع اكثر هل سنستطيع اعداد
اولادنا وبناتنا الى ما ينتظرهم في
المستقبل القريب
الايام القادمه عندها الجواب الاكيد لكني
ارجو الله من كل قلبي ان تكون الاجابه نعم
نستطيع شكرا
[تصفيق]